[Musik]
herzlich willkommen hier bei Bild an
Krieg kann man sich nicht gewöhnen an
das tägliche sterben aber doch der Krieg
in der Ukraine der ist mittlerweile
Alltag geworden nach einem Jahr es geht
nicht vor nicht zurück es geht einfach
immer weiter so Zeit für eine ehrliche
kriegsrechnung was haben unsere
Waffenlieferungen eigentlich gebracht
was haben unsere Sanktionen gebracht und
wie stark ist Putins Russland noch
darüber diskutiere ich jetzt mit diesen
Gästen nämlich mit August Henning bei
uns dem langjährigen Chef des deutschen
Auslandsgeheimdienstes BND Henning Orte
unionsverteidigungsexperte im Bundestag
und selbst übrigens Reserve Offizier mit
Erich Fahrt Brigadegeneral ARD hat lange
Jahre Angela Merkel im Kanzleramt
militärisch beraten und Alexander dubovi
Politik Analyst hat unter anderem in
Moskau studiert und er hat jetzt auch in
Wien herzlich willkommen in allen Herr
Orte wenn wir einmal einen Strich
runterziehen würden sie jetzt sagen
militärisch Putins Armee ist zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt deutlich geschwächt
gegenüber den Zeitpunkt vor einem Jahr
ja Pudding glaubte die Ukraine im
Schnelldurchgang einnehmen zu können das
ist nicht gelungen weil die Ukrainer
stark dagegen halten aber es wäre
genauso falsch zu glauben dass jetzt die
Ukrainer schnellsiegen werden als
Gegenthese wir müssen uns auf einen
langfristigen militärischen Konflikt ein
aber deutlich schwächer als vor einem
Jahr werden sie absolut ich würde auch
sagen putin ist in der Rückhand und
deswegen ist der gefährlich und deswegen
ist eine neue Offensive zu erwarten und
würden Sie sagen das ist auch ihre unser
aller die westliche Leistung mit das
Putin heute wie Sie es sagen schwächer
ist seine Armee als vor einem Jahr es
ist beeindruckend wie die Ukraine kämpft
mit welcher Intention und Motivation und
es ist auch die Geschlossenheit der
Europäischen Union und der NATO und auch
die Rückendeckung durch die Amerikaner
hey du würden sie das Einschätzen ist
Putins Armee heute so dass man sagen
kann deutlich weniger Durchschlagskraft
als vor einem Jahr in diesem 24 20
Februar als alles begann nein das würde
ich anders sehen die russische Arme hat
tatsächlich sehr viele Niederlagen
erleiden müssen nichts desto weniger
mittlerweile gelang aus der russischen
Führung hier die an mir zu konsolidieren
und sie steht wir stehen kurz vor einer
neuen Offensive und ich würde tunlichste
davon abraten die russische Armee zu
unterschätzen warum die russische Armee
gelang oder russischen einige lange
sondern vergangenen Wochen doch
eindrucksvolles zu leisten
und ohne die westlichen
Waffenlieferungen wird das für die
Ukraine sehr schwer dagegen zu halten
und aus diesem Grunde sind besonders die
kampfpanzerlieferungen sollten so
schnell wie möglich kommen noch bevor
der russischen jetzt reden wir nach fast
einem Jahr Herr Hanning über den Zustand
über die Stärke der des Militärs von
Putin
ja wir können größtenteils durch
spekulieren wir können die Nachrichten
zusammensetzen wie in Puzzle welche
Informationen haben Sie aktuell über den
Zustand der russischen Armee ja ich
glaube das ist sehr schwer für
Außenstehende man hört sehr
unterschiedliche Sichtweisen und wenn
man im Internet das verfolgt dann gibt
es die Sendung wiege-meldung von beiden
Seiten ich wäre also da hier sehr
vorsichtig gibt es irgendwelche Quellen
den sie trauen
na ja wie sagte Bismarck nirgendwo wird
so viel gelogen die während des Krieges
und nach der Jagd in so weit ist
Vorsicht geboten aber gleichwohl man
sieht natürlich im Augenblick ein
Stillstand man hat so den Eindruck dass
auf der einen Seite Quantität auf
russischer Seite gegen Qualität auf
ukrainischer Seite kämpft die Ukraine
ist mit modernen westlichen Technologien
ausgestattet wir reden immer über
Militärtechnik aber man muss auch die
Informationen sehen ich glaube das
westliche Nachrichtendienste zu liefern
und ein Teil der ukrainischen Erfolge
erklär t sich sicher auch aus dieser
engen Zusammenarbeit der
Nachrichtendienst mit Amerikaner mit
anderen westlichen Diensten ich glaube
das auch ein ganz entscheidender Faktor
jetzt haben wir gerade schon gehört der
ottel sagt na deutlich schwächer als vor
einigen Jahren
widerspricht da äh vehement wie würden
Sie mit welchen Worten mit welchen
Adjektiven Moment der Zustand von Potenz
Armee beschreiben
ich glaube dass die Armee sich
reorganisiert hat am Anfang hat sie
große Schwächen gezeigt er hat ja
zurecht auf die ursprüngliche Planung
hingewiesen das war ja ein Blitzkrieg
dann hat man versucht den Norden zu
besetzen dann hat man sich auf den Don
Bass konzentriert ich höre jetzt aus
Moskau und dass man die ganze Ukraine
einnehmen will ich habe Zweifel ob das
gelingt mit dem vorhandenen Kräften ich
glaube da müsste man die russische Arme
erheblich verstärken aber die
Entscheidung eine general mobil machen
und immer wieder erwartet wird hat sich
ja auch zumindest hingezögert er hat sie
nicht getroffen sie sagen das jetzt so
hören Sie aus Moskau was sind das für
Belege auf der Straße über Geheimdienst
Quellen also ich will nicht über meine
Quellen berichten aber ich höre schon
wie intern da überlegt wird gedacht wird
welche Kriegsziel verfolgt werden
ursprünglich die hinten Zertifizierung
wie es immer schön hieß jetzt setzt sich
auch mal die Sichtweise durch dass man
die ganze Ukraine angreifen will und
wobei man Zweifel hat wirklich
jedenfalls ob dazu die Ressourcen
ausreichen dann müsste man
wahrscheinlich ganz anders antreten wir
haben eben schon gehört dass ein
Offensive geplant ist nur da fragt man
sich mit welchen Kräften die Ukraine ist
flächenmäßig eine der größten
europäischen Staaten wenn Sie die
Ukraine besetzen wollen dann brauchen
Sie wahrscheinlich eine Million Soldaten
die im Augenblick ist im Moment schwer
zu glauben können wir an dem Tisch
natürlich auch nicht wäre fixieren was
sie aus Moskau hören und was dann an
diesen Quellen tatsächlich dran ist
erfahrt wie ist wir haben über die
Informationslage in diesem Krieg
gesprochen und haben versucht
rauszufinden in welchem Zustand ist
Putins Armee welche Informationslage
haben Sie also ich meine ich gehe fest
davon aus dass die Russen immer noch die
militärische Eskalation Dominanz im
Operationsgebiet haben das heißt Sie
können nachschieben
Personal Material Waffensysteme sie
haben die logistische Basis direkt
hinter sich
und sie man kann sie da letztlich nicht
an die Wand drücken das geht nicht auch
unsere Waffenlieferung auch die schweren
Kampfpanzer auch die 14 deutschen
Leopard 2 werden an dieser militärischen
Gesamtlage nichts ändern und der
amerikanische generalstadschef hat das
ja mehrfacher zuletzten Rammstein gesagt
das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich ist dass
man das militärisch drehen kann im Laufe
des Jahres und hat deswegen ja auch
geraten über andere Mittel und Wege
nachzudenken wie zum Beispiel politische
Verhandlungen sie haben am ersten
Kriegstag damals gesagt das wäre alles
nicht lange dauern voraussichtlich sie
haben genau gesagt militärisch gesehen
ist die Sache gelaufen meine Bewertung
ist dass es nur um ein paar Tage gehen
wird und nicht mehr sind sie froh dass
sie sich geirrt haben und dass diese
russische durchmachen nicht passiert ist
ja natürlich aber wir haben alle Anfang
des kriege ich kenne keinen Analysten
oder Experten der andere Meinung weil
wir haben alle geglaubt durch diese
schieren und numerische überlegen hatten
ja Russen dieser schnelle Zugriff auf
Kiel wird funktioniert und er
funktioniert er nicht und dann beginnt
ja die Verlegung in den Osten und dieses
langsame vorgehen aber auch erfolgreiche
vor gehen im dombas sind sie froh dass
sie gelernt haben
ja was heißt froh ich muss sagen ich
versuche immer Emotionen daraus zu
halten sondern die Lage so zu sehen wie
sie ist nicht und wir sind jetzt in
einem massiven abnutzungskrieg der
kostet jeden Tag uns Hunderte und
Tausende von Toten und
militärisch sehe ich nicht die
Möglichkeit das zu verändern einfach und
das treibt mich ein bisschen um wie
kommt man da raus und das ist ja das was
Mark Miley auch sagt wo er dann sagt
Mensch denkt doch mal über politische
Lösungswege nach permanente drüber
nachgedacht einzig es bleibt im Moment
das Gebiet herzustellen von der Ukraine
und das will man will vor allen Dingen
die Ukraine will auf der Westen
logischerweise nicht erfahren wir kommen
zu dem Punkt zurück wer noch einmal kurz
bleiben bei dem Punkt von Putins Armee
wir sehen Meldungen oder hörenmeldung
dass die Soldaten immer schlechter
ausgebildet sind man holt die aus dem
Knast die sind besoffen an der Front die
haben kaum Klamotten die kriegen kein
Essen das Material aus dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg und so weiter und so fort und
gleichzeitig ja du wie
werden Erfolge gefeiert von der
russischen Armee wie passt das zusammen
das sind natürlich begrenzte Erfolge und
die Mangelversorgung können wir hier
natürlich keinesfalls leugnen nicht
desto weniger kann Russlands die mobil
machen hier ausbauen denn die
generalmobil machen ist zwar nicht
befohlen worden aber so wie das
Präsident von Putin formuliert war
erlaubt dass einer der Faktor mobil
machen das heißt die einzige Institution
die über die Höhe der Rekruten
entscheidet ist das
Verteidigungsministerium ich wundere
mich nur ich wundere mich nur darüber es
werden mittlerweile recht moderne
Waffensysteme geliefert aus dem Westen
aus dem kompletten Westen im Grunde und
wir reden dann wir bekommen diese
Meldung über die Soldaten wie gesagt
schlecht ausgebildet keine Klamotten
schlechtes Material die Panzer aus dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg kann man dann sagen
Herr Otte die westlichen Waffenlieferung
waren bis heute in Erfolg wenn man es
nicht mehr schafft diese schlecht
ausgebildete Armee zurückzudrängen
auf jeden Fall notwendig ein Zeichen der
Solidarität zu setzen und sich am
militärischen Ziel der Ukraine zu
orientieren was erfolgreich nach einem
Jahr es war insofern erfolgreich als
dass die Ukraine durch Russland noch
nicht eingenommen werden konnte aber ich
will auch davor warnen zu glauben dass
man jetzt Russland unterschätzen könnte
denn sie können mit purer Masse mit
purer Quantität nachschieben mit
unbegrenzten Möglichkeiten und das macht
es so verdammt gefährlich also das
trauen sie auch der russische Armee zu
sie trauen ihr eine beispielsweise
früher als Offensive zu auch noch mal
ein Angriff auf die Hauptstadt auf Kia
spätestens im Frühjahr wenn ich sogar
jetzt wo die Böden gefroren sind und das
ist die große Sorge und deswegen sage
ich auch wir müssen wenn wir liefern und
das machen wir schneller liefern damit
man eher in die Situation gebracht wird
nämlich die Ukraine sich zu erwarten
noch einmal wie sie sagen beide da kommt
immer weiter Nachschub aus Russland
woher eigentlich woher nehmen die das
Soldaten
kommt aus der Bevölkerung und an
Material Russlands ist gerade dabei auf
Kriegswirtschaft umzustellen und sie
können diesen Schritt wesentlich
schneller vollziehen und nachhaltiger
als wir sie jemals könnten in unseren
demokratischen Gesellschaften und
zusätzlich hat Russland ja auch Partner
die ihnen Waffenlieferung es ist
einerseitsabkommen mit dem Iran
abgeschlossen über den Bau iranischer
Drohnen in Russland und der Russland
kauft auch Munition von Nordkorea ein
sie sagen gerade viel effizienter wie er
Brigadegeneral wie lange dauert das ein
Leopard zu bauen in Deutschland naja ich
habe mir sagen lassen also wenn man dort
die deutschen Rüstungsunternehmen und
vor allen Dingen eins könnte sicherlich
100 Leopard 2 im Jahr bauen aber die
bräuchten eben auch eine gewisse
Vorlaufzeit um diese ganzen
Fertigungslinie zu bauen die Dokumente
und ja ich denke das geht nicht von
heute auf morgen nicht also
eben da das heißt es limitiert das heißt
wir bräuchten jetzt wir reden aktuell ja
über die Lieferung von Panzern die in
der Garage standen jetzt entstaubt
werden kampffähig gemacht werden und und
und wenn man jetzt Nachschub bräuchte
wir reden über die Nachschub auf der
russischen Seite würde das Jahre dauern
richtig naja wir haben ja wir hatten mal
vor kurzem also noch vor zwei drei
Jahren das hat mir mal der Schweizer
generaladschaftchef scherzhaft gesagt
wir Schweizer haben mehr Kampfpanzer als
ihr einsatzbereit wir haben jetzt eine
Kampfpanzer Volumen von roundabout 300
Stück nicht davon ist ein weißen die
Hälfte oder 60% ist einsatzbereit mehr
nicht und davon geben wir eine ganze
Panzer Kompanie jetzt in die Ukraine
aber gleichzeitig sind wir möchten mal
festhalten der Orte in der Produktion
langsamer und ineffizienter als Russland
ja weil in einer Autokratie kann anders
entschieden werden als in der privat
organisierten Rüstungswirtschaft aber
lassen nämlich sagenweise im Sommer
letzten Jahr was hat der Deutsche
Bundestag mit breiter Mehrheit
beschlossen das schweres Gerät der auch
keine zur Verfügung gestellt wird und
jetzt haben wir gerade die Diskussion
hinter uns und der Kanzler hat mal alle
mal 14 Kampfpanzer zur Verfügung
gestellt das ist genau das Problem an
dem wir leiden das zu wenig und zu spät
bereitgestellt wird so oder so aber es
muss das heißt das entscheidende dauert
auch noch lange wenn wir jetzt über
Nachschub reden und das hat ja auch die
Bundesregierung angedeutet Herr Habeck
hat das ja in jedem Interview gesagt
dass es dabei natürlich nicht bleiben
wird dass die Panzer irgendwann auch
vernichtet sein würden oder man an
anderer Stelle eben Nachschub braucht
das heißt man muss sich darüber ja
Gedanken machen jetzt und wenn wir jetzt
hören von dem Fahrrad sie selber
bestätigen es dauert so lange ist das in
dem abnutzungsring eine verdammt
schlechte Nachricht also ich war eine
vor einer Euphorie derer die sagen jetzt
gehen wir mal dieses Fakten Gerät und
jenes waffengerät das müsste im übrigen
die Militärs entscheiden wir sind ja in
Deutschland eine Situation dass wir über
einzelne Waffensysteme diskutieren wir
müssen über Fähigkeiten reden orientiert
wenn der militärischen Strategie der
Ukraine aber dennoch muss früher
entschieden werden und es muss auch ein
Gesamt unterstützungskon Tipp geben für
die Ukraine wir leben von einem Tag in
den anderen und das ist das Recht nicht
wirklich der Unentschiedenheit der Ampel
zu haben ihn verstanden was wir mit den
oder der ganze Westen mit den
Waffenlieferungen erreichen möchte in
der Ukraine glaube wir haben ja schon
viele erreicht aber wir haben erst mal
erreicht dass die Ukraine Widerstand
leisten können und zwar erfolgreich und
zwar einmal mit Waffensystem aber ich
glaube auch was so die
Informationsversorgung betrifft was
eigentlich bei uns in der öffentlichen
Diskussion immer heruntergeht ich halte
das für ganz wichtig also ich glaube
dass das durchaus erfolgreich war aber
Russland hat erhebliche Ressourcen das
ist nicht so unterschätzen auf der
anderen Seite wenn ich mir die
Ressourcen nordwestlicher Seite anschaue
da würde ich dann nicht nur alleine auf
Produktion in Deutschland abstellen
sondern es gibt ja auch
Panzerlieferungen aus Großbritannien aus
den USA gehört haben ich glaube nach wie
vor von Nachschub her
kann der Westen schon mithalten also
wenn ich sehe was über Polen zum Teil
auch über Rumänien geliefert wird das
ist schon ganz erheblich noch mithalten
wie noch mal auf diese Nachrichten
zerrissene Klamotten besoffene Soldaten
schlechtes Material und jetzt sagen Sie
nein nach einem Jahr der ganze Westen
die ganzen Nato-Partner da sind wir
schon in der Lage mitzuhalten was die
Materialversorgung betrifft und ich
glaube die keine hätte ja nicht so
Widerstand leisten können ohne die ganz
erhebliche westliche Unterstützung das
muss mehr deutlich sehen vor allen
Dingen aus den USA ich meine sind ja
riesen Pakete geschnürt worden und die
Ukraine war ja in der Lage überraschen
für viele für mich auch Widerstand zu
leisten und durchaus auch Erfolge zu
erzielen das muss man ja sehen die haben
ja die Hälfte des ursprünglich eroberten
Gebietes zurückerobert auch das gehört
ja mit zum Kriegsgeschehen das heißt der
Krieg wäre wenn es die westlich
Waffenlieferung auch die deutschen
Waffenlieferung dann schließlich nicht
gegeben hätte möglicherweise vorbei ja
das glaube ich
sie haben enge Drähte auf beide Seiten
ich habe gerade schon gesagt sie haben
auch in Moskau studiert sie haben auch
enge Drähte in die Ukraine wie würden
sie im Moment auf beiden Seiten die
Stimmung beschreiben wie groß ist die
Unterstützung für diese Operation für
diesen Krieg die Unterstützung in
Ukraine ist nach wie vor sehr groß
natürlich muss der Präsident wurde
selenski aktuell die Bevölkerung für
eine weitere mobil machen hier
startbereit machen und in Russland hohe
Verluste natürlich auf beiden Seiten
natürlich diese Verluste werden zwar
nicht immer kommuniziert offiziell aber
man versteht sie aus also Statistiken
sprechen zum Beispiel auf russischer
Seite von 5000 Toten pro Woche etwa
halten Sie das für realistisch durchaus
ich glaube Magie hat sie ja im Dezember
von weit über 100000 toten Soldaten auf
beiden Seiten gesprochen er hat zwar
keine genauen Zahlen genannt aber das
wird es wahrscheinlich ja übertreffen
auf beiden Seiten also etwa in der
Balance oder schätzen Sie die
ukrainischen Opfer deutlich höher ein
ich denke dass die
Opfer auf der russischen Seite durchaus
höher sein können
insbesondere auch aufgrund der Tatsache
dass wir so gut wie nicht gerne
nachweisbaren Daten aus Russland
bekommen über die Verluste der Ukraine
wesentlichen Bescheid aber über die
Verluste Russlands eben nicht das heißt
während die ukrainische Gesellschaft
sehr wohl kann fähig ist und weiterhin
außerhalb ist die russische Gesellschaft
weitgehend innovativer fallen und lässt
diesen Krieg über sich einfach ergeben
das einzige Zeitpunkt wo der Krieg
tatsächlich in den Wohnzimmer der
Menschen angekommen ist war im September
vergangenen Jahres als die
immobilienmachung befohlen wurde und das
war auch der Zeitpunkt wo ist er
kurzzeitig
vergleichsweise gefährlich für solche
geworden ist denn die Menschen sind
damals auch auf die Straße gegangen nie
also wenige in den Großstädten sondern
vor allem im nordgarten und auch in den
Ehrenmann und Republiken Russlands ja
wir wollen natürlich gemeinsam
rausfinden die meistgestellte Frage wann
ist der Zeitpunkt wo es aus dem Krieg in
ja an die verhandlungsstische geht wann
ist dieser Zeitpunkt gekommen was würden
Sie im Moment sagen ganz kurze Antwort
vielleicht einmal die Runde heute was
ist dieser Zeitpunkt also wann geht es
von beiden Seiten an Verhandlungstisch
dann wenn Konditionen festlegen mit
denen die Ukraine leben kann also die
Ukraine braucht einen starken Frieden
war militärische sportsituation sind
Zeitpunkt wo Russland nicht mehr
weiterkommt und die Ukraine auch gerne
weiteren Erfolge erzielen kann das ist
die Grundvoraussetzung
gesellschaftssituation
ja ich glaube wir hatten mehrere Momente
auch im letzten Jahr wo man hätte
verhandeln können die ersten
Verhandlungen liefen ja März April
zwischen Ukrainern muss wussten dann gab
es auch nach der nach dem Abzug aus
vielleicht eine Gelegenheit und jetzt
natürlich auch damals gescheitert also
das kommt ja aus Israel diese Meldung da
von der Seite wird ja behaupte damals
lag alles auf dem Tisch und einige
Nato-Partner hätten das so heißt es von
dort ja nicht zu dem Zeitpunkt gewollt
naja ich glaube ich aus meiner Bewertung
haben vor allem der Amerikaner und die
Briten ist nicht gewollt weil sie auch
die
signaturenmächte des Budapester
Memorandums sind von 1994 dass die
territoriale Integrität der Ukraine
feststellte gewollt haben
damals ja noch nicht so also
stimmt prognostiziert haben sondern das
ist ganz lange dauert das stimmt aber
das widersprach natürlich dem Geist
dieses Abkommens und das deswegen
konnten die beiden gar nicht ja sagen
und deswegen hat man es eben vom Tisch
geholt denke ich also ich meine
realistischer
was dort gesagt wird eine Verschwörung
also ich glaube wir sind im Augenblick
einer Lage das beide Seiten auch so
Bäume geklettert sind das ist sehr
schwer ist sich ein Frieden vorzustellen
ja und erfahrungsgemäß ist es so es
kommt nur zu einem Friedensschluss wenn
eine Seite zumindest schwächelt und gab
es damals den Moment also im März halten
Sie das für realistisch glaube es gab
einen Moment und wenn zutrifft was wir
in den Medien hören dass die Ukrainer
bereit waren in Sachen don-bass und auch
in Sachen Grimm einzugehen das war ja so
die Grundidee ich glaube schon dass
damals der Chance bestanden hätte aber
die wurde eben halt nicht benutzt man
fragt sich das ist ja eine irre Mail und
so und man liest es und den kann
eigentlich nicht sein ja warum sollten
die das nicht wollen halten sie das äh
sehr sagen gerade sie halten das
durchaus für realistisch aber warum
sollte jemand im Westen das nicht
gewollt haben
naja ich meine das waren Eroberungskrieg
jetzt der Russen ganz am Anfang
wurde ja deutlich dass die russische
Armee bei weitem nicht so stark war wie
man das ursprünglich angenommen hat und
ich glaube man hat darauf gehofft dass
die Ukraine sich erfolgreich zu Wehr
setzt was dann ja auch geschehen ist und
man hofft eben durch diese starke
Unterstützung der Ukraine ich glaube der
amerikanische Außenminister oder gesagt
auch Russland zu schwächen das muss man
ja auch sagen ist auch ein
amerikanisches Ziel das ist auch
gelungen das heißt dass die
Verhandlungsposition im nächsten Monaten
nach dem März eben besser wird
vorübergehend war das möglicherweise
auch der Fall ist es gibt ja böse
Stimmen die sagen mit 5%, das
amerikanischen verteilungshaushalt wir
sind 50 % geschwächtigt das muss man
sehen
jetzt haben sie gerade gesagt
militärischer hat wird die Voraussetzung
sein um an die verhandlungstische beide
Seiten zurückzubringen der Militär
Historiker hat das so auf den Punkt
gebracht er hat in dieser Woche gesagt
na der Krieg ist ganz Bar aus Sicht der
vor allen Dingen Russlands noch nicht
schrecklich genug
irgendwann gibt es einen Punkt an dem
auch Russland die russische Gesellschaft
sagen würde genug ist genug aber wo
dieser Punkt ist und wo der Punkt in der
Ukraine ist das wissen wir nicht und
leider muss ich sagen ich bin jetzt mal
ganz ganz direkt und sage es sind
wahrscheinlich leider noch nicht genug
Menschen gestorben um diesen Krieg zu
beenden das klingt schrecklich zynisch
aber hat er Recht hat darf ich
vielleicht kurz ergänzen sondern was
vorher gesagt wurde ich ja denke wir
sollten sehr vorsichtig sein und hier
die russischen narrative nicht so stark
aufzunehmen denn es gehört zu den
zentralen russischen dass der Westen die
Verhandlungen scheitern ist ganz so ist
das nicht deswegen habe ich was sollte
das Interesse sein was soll das
Interesse der Verhandlungen ansehen so
ähm wollte Russland ja den
Waffenstillstand nicht zustimmen sondern
die Kampfhandlungen weiterführen auch
während der Verhandlungen und zwar die
beiden
verhandlungsmannschaften also von
ukraineischen und russischen Seite haben
sich auch sehr gut verstanden allerdings
ist scheitert das letztlich an Vladimir
Putin denn Russland verlangte zu diesem
Zeitpunkt verlangt nach wie vor ein
Diktat Frieden das heißt die Ukraine hat
alle russischen Forderungen zu erfüllen
ein wichtiger Punkt der vielleicht für
Westen ein Problem darstellt die
sogenannte endnazifizierung gehört dazu
die komplette endmilitarisierung wenn
wir von einer sogenannten
Entnazifizierung sprechen so ist das
nichts anderes als der Wunsch Russlands
die politische Führung der Ukraine durch
eine pro russische Marionetten
auszutauschen so ist das es ist sehr
einfach erklärt das ist einfach
logischerweise nicht zu erfüllen Seite
selbstverständlich was finden mitunter
ein Problem gewesen sein könnte ist das
die Ukraine sehr weitreichende
Sicherheitsgarantien forderte und äh die
im Grunde genommen einen NATO-Beitritt
gleich kennen praktischen arbeitet es
ist aber noch lange kein Grund zu sagen
der Westen hat die Verhandlungen
scheitern lassen das war mit Sicherheit
nicht der Fall das heißt sie sagen die
Argumentation die Möglichkeit gegeben im
März das ist im Grunde Propaganda sagen
sie weil die Möglichkeit hat uns gegeben
aber es schädelte an Moskau ja jetzt
reden wir gerade über die Möglichkeit an
den Verhandlungstisch zurückzukehren und
ich habe ihn gerade die Aussage von
Militärhistoriker synkanalzel gezeigt
der sagt ganz zynisch gesagt es sind
einfach noch nicht genügend Tote auf dem
Schlachtfeld gestorben genügend Menschen
auf dem Schlachtfeld gestorben es müsste
der Krieg noch schrecklicher werden vor
allen Dingen für Russland damit sie
gezwungen sind an den Verhandlungstisch
zu gehen wesentlich schreckliche kamen
diese Krieg für die Ukraine nicht mehr
werden da wir sollten bedenken wie viele
Kriegsverbrechen nachgewiesene bereits
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt nachgewiesen
Krieg vorbei
gegangen hat er bezieht das auch
verstehen
denn davon sprechen die die russischen
Führungszeugnis
für Russland haben belangt wie wie wie
bereits gesagt
Konflikt ist um den Köpfen der Russinnen
und Russen nicht angekommen und das wird
auch lange nicht der Fall sein denn
aktuell
bemüht sich die russische Propaganda
damit dieser Krieg auch nicht ankommt
ich will das nur noch mal aufgreifen
weil das ja auch darauf zählt was sie
sagen es muss militärisches Pass geben
jetzt sagt so im kanalzel es ist noch
nicht schrecklich genug zumindest dann
für Russland noch nicht das heißt unsere
westlichen Waffen müssten noch tödlicher
sein müssten mehr Schrecken verbreiten
damit Putin einlenkt man das das Leid in
den Familien ist schon enorm groß es
gibt Dörfer da gibt es keine Männer mehr
unter 25 und dafür gibt es einen Grund
dass es nicht öffentlich ist weil die
gesamte Social Media
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit ist eingestellt
weil es gibt keine Opposition mehr keine
Interesse die darüber berichtet und das
ist doch mehr ein Indiz dafür was Putin
hat und deswegen wird es jetzt auch kein
Waffenstillstand geben denn er würde
diese Chance nur nutzen sich
aufzufrischen zu stärken und dann nach
links oder rechts auszuweichen große
Sorge der baltischen Staaten ja ich frag
so zynisch weil das möglicherweise ja
war es was der Militärhistoriker sagt
sie müssen die Ukraine mit westlicher
Unterstützung noch mehr töten damit
Putin an den verhandlungstischen das ist
das so das sehe ich nicht so sondern es
geht darum die Ukraine zu stärken zu
unterstützen im militärischen Vorgehen
nämlich den russischen wirklich
Offensive zurückzudrängen und Gebiet
zurück zu erobern aber irgendwann werden
die Mütter der gefallenen russischen
Soldaten aufstehen und diese sogenannte
spezialoperation wirklich benennen als
ein anderes
Russland lange lange drauf warten nein
ich fühlte das ist nicht so oder können
wir sehr lange darauf warten die die
wesentliche Frage ist die politischen
Proteste am aktuellen Russland absolut
keine Chance der einzige von Gott ist
die Regierung gefährlich werden könnte
sind sozial motivierte Proteste und dazu
müsste der Lebensstandard oder die
gewohnte Lebensführung die Bevölkerung
enorm und sich sehr schnell nach unten
verändert sich enorm verschlechtern und
zwar schönen beispielsweise die
Sanktionen dazu sehr stark beitragen
darüber reden wir dass es genau das
Stichwort wir haben jetzt lange über das
militärische über die Stärke oder
Schwäche der putinischen Armee
gesprochen wollen einmal über die
Wirkung der Sanktionen sprechen ganz
wichtig vom ersten Kriegstag an
beschlossen auf EU-Ebene und es hieß
sofort kraftvolle Sanktionen
mittlerweile geht man in die zehnte
Stufe dieser Sanktion und die
EU-Kommissarin sagt man habe die
russische Wirtschaft ganz erheblich
geschwächt ist es so ja nicht also wenn
man sich die Zahlen angesagt kann man
den Eindruck gewinnen kurzfristig nicht
wobei mit Statistik und zahlen werde ich
immer sehr vorsichtig die müssen nicht
stimmen aus Moskau ganz im Gegenteil ich
glaube nur an die Statistik die ich
selbst gefälscht habe
aber der der Rubel etwas so angeblich
wie gehen
die russische Wirtschaft schlägt sich
besser als erwartet das kann man schon
so sagen
mittellangfristig sieht das anders aus
weil ich glaube die russische Wirtschaft
war immer sehr stark auf die enge
Zusammenarbeit mit westlichen Firmen mit
dem besten angewiesen das ging über den
Gas zusammen also mittellangfristig
sagen sie waren
zusammenbrechen würde ich nicht sagen
sie leiden darunter das kostet
Wirtschaftswachstum das kostet
Zukunftsperspektiven ich glaube das ist
das entscheidende ich glaube kein
Zusammenbruch den den sehe ich mir dafür
gibt es die ganzen Rohstoffreserven das
können wir weiter für äußern nach Asien
auch andere Gegend ich glaube in
Zusammenbruch ist nicht zu erwarten aber
eine Verlangsamung natürlich das
Wachstums und auch ein aber das klingt
doch so wenn wir so viel Worte brauchen
um die Wirkung unserer Sanktion zu
beschreiben dass sie nicht die Wirkung
hatten ganz offenbar hat die man
beabsichtigt hat ab dem Kriegsbeginn
ja das stimmt aber ich möchte noch mal
kurz was zu diesem abnutzungsgedanken
sagen den der vorne sind ich finde diese
Diskussion es sind nicht genug gestorben
es müssen noch mehr sterben absurd der
amerikanische generalstadschef hat
gesagt 200.000 gefallen auf beiden
Seiten 50.000 ziviltote Millionen
Flüchtlinge wir haben das Beispiel von
abnutzungsschlachten aus dem ersten
Weltkrieg vor berton sind fast eine
Million junger Franzosen und deutscher
gefallen von nothing weil dieser
abnutzungsgedanke wie gesund genau sagt
auf beiden Seiten so transparent so
wichtig so gewichtig war dass sie
annahmen da führen wir die Entscheidung
dabei wir nutzen und so weit ab bis der
andere nicht mehr kann und in dieser
Phase sind wir im Moment in der Ukraine
und das ist das fürchterliche brutale
was man einfach sehen muss und wo man
rauskommen muss dann bleiben wir noch im
Moment dabei erfahren ein Stück weit
ertappt weil das natürlich im Moment
genau das ist was stattfindet auf beiden
Seiten ungefähre Ballons bisschen hinnen
ein bisschen zurück Erfolg immer
eigentlich derselbe der dasselbe
Schlachtfeld auf beiden Seiten einen
brutaler abnutzungskrieg das haben wir
gehört ungefähr 5000 Tote pro Woche auf
beiden Seiten und kein Ausweg ist das
möglicherweise auch das erklärte Ziel
genau diesen abnutzungskrieg länger zu
ziehen nein Russland weiter zu schwächen
nein das darf es nicht sein das ist auch
nicht unser Interesse es ist klarer
Bruch des Völkerrechts es ist ein
Angriffskrieg und wir dürfen dem
stärkeren nicht nachgeben sondern das
Recht muss oder umgesetzt werden weil
die gesamte europäische Friedensordnung
wird damit angegriffen aber wir wollen
ja auch ein Zeichen setzen zu sagen es
wird sich nicht lohnen für Russland eine
neue Offensive beispielsweise vielleicht
auch nein wenn ich sage brauchen Sie
noch mehr Waffen müssen sie noch
brutaler vorgehen müssen Sie den fein
konsequenter zurückdrängen dort in der
Ukraine sagen sie auch nein das heißt
sie sie bleiben ja genau bei dieser
Balance bei diesem abnutzen ich sage wir
müssen auf dem Gefechtsfeld überlegen
sein und deswegen ist ja auch die
panzerdebatte weil man eben eine Feuer
Überlegenheit erzielen muss die Ukraine
in die Situation zu versetzen sich auch
erfolgreich wehren zu können damit die
nächste Offensive hoffentlich nicht
kommt sehen Sie hier den Ausweg aus
diesem abnutzungskrieg Herfahrt den sie
gerade so emotional kritisiert haben
also ich denke sie halt die militärische
Ausweglosigkeit wenn wir das
Weitermachen ja dann sterben tausende
jeden Tag ne aber wir schaffen es nicht
da rauszukommen dieser Krieg ist
militärisch nicht entscheidbar das heißt
wir schaffen keine militärische Lösung
dann müssen wir unsere vor weiteren
Waffen liefern mal definieren welche
politischen Ziele wir haben das ist ja
eben angesprochen worden wollen wir die
Ukraine in die Lage versetzen dombas und
können zurückzuerobern wollen wir Sie in
die Lage versetzen Russland entscheiden
zu schlagen oder wollen wir sie so weit
stabilisieren dass die Voraussetzung für
Verhandlungen möglich ist
also wer ist wir wir sind natürlich
natürlich Deutschland als Teil der
Europäischen Union und der NATO aber am
Ende muss es auch das Bundeskabinett
deutlich mal sagen wofür wir stehen das
ist rein exekutives handeln und da hat
der Deutsche Bundestag dem Kabinett die
Möglichkeit gegeben Waffen zu liefern
und ich kritisiere nochmal nicht nur das
immer zu spät debattiert besonders
einzelne Waffensysteme gefährdet und was
fehlt teilweise ist eine Strategie zu
sagen was will Europa
Überzeugung wie sie gerade sagen nur sie
haben den zugestimmt ohne zu wissen was
mit den Leoparden auf dem sie selbst
übrigens saßen in ihrer in ihrer Zeit
bei der Bundeswehr sie haben den
zugestimmt die Leoparden zu schicken
ohne zu wissen was damit passieren soll
nein es ist zwar ganz klar wozu die da
sind nämlich die nächste Offensive
abzuwehren gesagt ihn fehlt die
Strategie die Strategie Europas fehlt
mir ja wir diskutieren über einzelne
Systeme und dies orientiert sich aber
auch am Willen des ukrainischen Volkes
sondern der Strategie silenski sondern
der sagt ja ganz klar zurückdrängen des
ähm russischen
bis vielleicht auf die Linie 24 februar
und zu vermeiden dass die nächste
Großoffensive Russlands Erfolg hat und
deswegen hoffentlich nicht startet wenn
Sie das Hören jetzt ist der Ort und
nicht Teil des Bundeskabinetts
kritisiert das Schaf dafür dass das eben
nicht so klar ausgesprochen ist sie als
Wissenschaftler verzweifeln Sie nicht
daran dass man so große Anstrengung
mittlerweile wirtschaftlich
finanziell ja auch für uns alle und dann
aber eben auch militärisch unternimmt
ohne die große Strategie nun zugespitzt
formuliert frieden gibt es nicht zu
Nulltarif und dessen sollten wir uns
bewusst sein das ist mir der erste Punkt
der zweite Punkt ist strategischen
Zielsetzungen sind von US-amerikanischen
Präsidenten Joseph beiden im Mai
vergangenen Jahres in der New York Times
sondern Leitartikel vorgeschlagen worden
und zwar ging es darum um die Stärkung
der Ukraine bis eine militärische
pazifikation erreichen und dann Beitrag
jetzt mal auf einen Satz zusammen zu
kürzen
sollten wir tatsächlich wollen dass der
zu Ende geht kann der Krieg bereits
morgen zu Ende gehen wir müssen nur
heute damit aufhören die Ukraine zu
unterstützen der Winterkrieg sehr
schnell zu Ende gehen wirklich sehr
schnell
mit diesem Ergebnis glücklich sein
werden
ehrlich gesagt denn so wie sie Herfahrt
gesagt haben dann wird das täglich
tausende Tote Ukraine geben denn wir
brauchen nur unseren Blick darauf zu
richten wie es dann der ukrainischen
Bevölkerung in den von Russland teil
besetzten Gebieten geht das ist reinster
vollkommen oder zumindest sind wir
bereits in der Schwelle zum
bevölkermarkt unzählige Kriegsverbrechen
diese wäre am Ende der Kriegshandlungen
nicht aufhören sondern die werden erst
richtig beginnen und wir sollten auch
nicht vergessen wie viele Kinder von von
der Rosen vom von Russland führt wurden
und so zwangsreduktion freigegeben
wurden also wenn das kein Völkermarkt
ist dann bitte definieren Sie Völkermord
also wir sollten hier sehr sehr
vorsichtig sein dass ich denke dass eine
militärische bazsituation auf jeden Fall
sehr benswert ist diese wird das aber
ohne die Unterstützung der Ukraine durch
den Westen nicht geben wir haben darüber
gesprochen gestritten diskutiert was
auch unsere militärische Unterstützung
für die Ukraine bisher tatsächlich
gebracht hat um herauszufinden wie ist
ein Ausweg aus diesem Krieg wir wollen
weiter darüber streiten was haben die
wirtschaftlichen Sanktionen gebracht in
diese in diesem Ukraine Krieg das tun
wir gleich nachher ganz kurzen Pause
[Musik]
zurück bei Bild die richtigen Fragen und
wir streiten über die Frage wie es
eigentlich weitergeht in diesem Ukraine
Krieg kein vor kein Zurück in der
militärische passsituation
möglicherweise in den nächsten Wochen in
den nächsten Monaten und kein ja wahrer
Ausweg aus diesem Krieg was haben unsere
Wirtschaftssanktionen eigentlich bis
heute gebracht das frage ich den
verteidigungspolitischen Sprecher im
Bundestag von der Union Henning Orte der
bei uns ist können Sie das sagen es gab
große Ziele die Wirtschaft so weit zu
schwächen das Putin diesen Krieg so
nicht mehr führen kann ist nach einem
Jahr nicht passiert haben die
wirtschaftssektion keinen Erfolg sie
haben Erfolg aber man kann nicht glauben
dass das Russland vom militärischen
Vorgehen abhalten würde das war das Ziel
unsere Long Term war es das Ziel
Russland deutlich zu machen dass sie
einen falschen Weg gehen und es ist auch
klar dass bei erhöhten Energiepreisen
erstmal
ein neues Geld nach Russland kommt aber
sie werden langfristig abgekoppelt
Labor oder im März der hieß es nicht
nach vorübergehen werden die Russen
erstmal profitieren davon sondern es war
kraftvoll wir werden dramatisch die
härtesten Sanktionen die es je gegeben
hat nach einem Jahr zwar nicht meine
spreche sondern wir kennen die
Sanktionen aus 214 damals war die
ukrainische Armee nicht in der Lage sich
zu erwehren militärisch nicht gut
ausgebildet die Zeit ist jetzt genutzt
worden aber jetzt musste ja auch ein
politisches Zeichen auch der
Wirtschaftlichkeit gesetzt werden aber
zu glauben dass das übern and only way
wäre das ist naiv aber warum steht der
Rubel jetzt glauben wir einmal zumindest
annähernd den Statistiken die wir lösen
können lesen können andere Meldungen
haben wir nicht der Rubel soll ungefähr
so stark sein wie bei Kriegsbeginn das
Produkt ist gestiegen in der Zeit die
Inflation soll in diesem Jahr 5 % nach
Voraussage betragen in Russland der wenn
man in Deutschland froh wenn man aktuell
5 % hätten also wie kann das sein bei so
massiven wirtschaftsaktion weil die
Wiesen ins Land fließen russland hat
sich Partner gesucht für Energie
Saudi-Arabien und zum Beispiel zweitens
gibt es eine Rüstungsindustrie die
zurzeit wahnsinnig angekurbelt wird und
der dritte Punkt ist es kommt auch neue
Technologie über Umwege hinein die uns
nicht gefallen es ist gesagt worden eine
über Nordkorea beispielsweise über Iran
und nichtsdestotrotz gehört es zum
Instrumentenkasten dazu diese Sanktionen
zu fahren klar die Frage ist inwieweit
sie wirken und ob sie tatsächlich dort
ansetzen wo sie ansetzen sollen ja du wo
wir sie können uns den Blick aus dem
Land aus Russland direkt geben Starbucks
ist raus mcDonald's ist raus aber die
Supermarktregale sind voll oder nun äh
grundsätzlich ja äh was aber nicht
bedeutet das ist kurzfristig beliebte
russische Wirtschaft wieder Erwarten
stabil was aber nicht bedeutet dass es
auch mittel bis langfristig der Fall
sein wird und dann sollten wie lange wie
lange muss man da warten also wir reden
über ein Abnutzung Skizze haben wir in
der in der Runde gemacht jetzt reden wir
über ganz ganz lange Zeiträumen bis
Sanktionen wird das Funktionen haben wir
Zeit
aber das ist zu glauben wenn wir heute
die Sanktionen verhängen das groß und in
einem Monat zusammenbricht
Monate ich will sie jetzt nicht
festnageln auf einen Monat aber sagen
sie uns sie reden über Zeiträume reden
sie über fünf Jahre Russland ist in
einer tiefen Wirtschaftskrise diese
Wirtschaftskrise zeigt sich mitunter
nicht aber einzelne Bereiche der
russischen Wirtschaft hängen am tropft
der Stadt ist und sind ohne Subventionen
nicht überlebensfähig die
Einwurf hier gerade das ist das ist
leider nicht unbedingt vergleichbar denn
wir sitzen hier und können frei und
offen über die wirtschaftlichen Probleme
diskutieren das ist ein Russland mit
dichten der Fall das heißt wir bekommen
bestimmt mitunter beschönigt der Zahlen
vorgelegt dann sollten wir nicht
vergessen Deutschland verfügt nicht über
diese Ressourcen Basis ist wie es
russland hat das heißt Russland
verscherbelt gerade die natürlichen
Ressourcen Russland wird mittel bis
langfristig zu
energiepolitischen Anhängsel Chinas und
das ist etwas was die russischen
Strategen seit Beginn der 90er Jahre
vermeiden wollten das ist der Albtraum
Russlands die gerade in Erfüllung geht
und das sollten wir nicht auf elf Monate
schauen um wenn wir fünf bis zehn Jahre
sind dann wird die russische Wirtschaft
in einem vollkommenen Zustand sein auf
eine kurze Antwort noch mal zu
fokussieren würden Sie sagen die
Wirtschaftssanktionen des Westens der EU
die wirken absolut die
wirtschaftsfunktion hatten drei
Zielsetzungen die erste Zielsetzung war
die Minimierung der russischen Einnahmen
damit das militärgeschwächt wird
indirekt zweite Zielsetzung mit Ukraine
dieses Ziel ist erreicht und die
Konsolidierung der westlichen
Gemeinschaft abermals erreicht das ist
zwei von drei Zielsetzungen sind sofort
erreicht worden und die dritte
Zielsetzung wird mit Sicherheit erreicht
werden sie haben gerade sofort gesagt
der Partner ja also unsere Wirtschaft
auch bei uns wirken die Sanktionen
sozusagen auch würden im Moment sagen
diese zwölf Monate kriegt die zeigen
Russland kann irgendwie doch ganz gut
auch ohne uns nämlich dann mit China und
Saudi-Arabien und so weiter wir können
aber sehr schwer ohne Russland ich
glaube die Koks bei den Sanktionen ist
das nicht alle damit machen ja die
Chinesen machen nicht mit die Inder
machen nicht mit die Israelis machen
nicht mit die Hälfte der arabischen die
Masse der arabischen Welt machen die
Türken machen nicht mit die meisten
afrikanischen Staaten machen nicht mit
die russischen Exporte Blumen die
russische Volkswirtschaft wächst und im
Gegensatz dazu geht unsere
Volkswirtschaft runter nicht unsere
Exporte brechen zusammen unsere
Unternehmen wandern ab gehen im Konkurs
oder verlassen eben das Land das muss
man sehen ich habe wirklich große Frau
also wenn ich langfristig mag das
richtig sein dass irgendwann da der
Zusammenbruch kommt aber ich sehe ihn
nicht ich sehe eigentlich ewige Farbe
bei uns zu Hause das ist hier kritisch
Wert von der wirtschaftlichen Stabilität
her und damit im Kontext auch die
soziale Qualität und damit auch
vielleicht die politische Stabilität wir
sollten das nicht so einfach aus dem
Blickwinkel nehmen
Putin lacht im Grunde überhaupt komplett
andere Sicht der Dinge als er fragt ich
glaube dass die russische Wirtschaft
ganz erheblich leidet die sind auf
westliche Hochtechnologie angewiesen und
zum Beispiel die Pipelines werden mit
Microsoft der Software betrieben die
Erschließung der Öl- und Gasfelder mit
moderner westlicher Technologie
Gastraum hat in Europa Geld verdient und
nicht in China und in Asien ich glaube
das mittelangfristig die russische Armee
russische Wirtschaft ganz erheblich
geschmecken und ich bin da völlig ihrer
Meinung und ich glaube dass die
Sanktionen wirken werden und ich glaube
dass man sich in Moskau auch erhebliche
Sorgen macht deswegen wie viele Jahre
wird das dauern das ist schwer zu sagen
aber ich glaube dass die
Einnahmeausfälle sich schon auswirken
werden also ich kann das schlecht
prognostizieren aber Mittel langfristig
wird sich das glaube ich dramatisch
sie sagen sollen sich da nicht festlegen
kann das auch verstehen
als langjähriger und mittlerweile sich
im Ruhestand befindlicher BND-Chef und
doch ist es ja total wichtig wenn wir
über 5000 Tote pro Woche auf beiden
Seiten reden dann macht es eben was aus
ob es um zwei Wochen oder um 2 Jahre
geht haben ich glaube das sagt uns
jemand an Mittel und langfristiges Thema
und natürlich muss man sich im Moskau
bezahlen können machen wie wollen wir
eigentlich unterkünftiges Verhältnis zu
Europa gestalten wollen wir sozusagen
auf Dauer ein feindschaftliches
Verhältnis zu Europa haben oder wollen
wir nicht doch im Ergebnis wieder mit
Europa kooperieren auch aus
wirtschaftlichen gesellschaftlichen
Gründen das ist die die Kernfrage aber
auch für uns ich glaube nicht frage ich
glaube nicht dass wir jetzt über
Sanktionen in militärische
Entscheidungen erzwingen das glaube ich
nicht teilweise möglicherweise bei
modernen Waffensystem wo Chips fehlen
und so weiter da gibt's ja
unterschiedliche Darstellungen
Nachrichten aber ich glaube die
Sanktionen bewirken jetzt nicht
unmittelbar am Ende des Krieges aber sie
schwächen Russland perspektivisch Ende
des kriegesellschaft Stichwort noch mal
wir reden darüber wie wir da alle
gemeinsam rauskommen formulieren Sie
einmal noch mal ganz klar das Ziel was
ist das Ziel aus westlicher aus
Deutschland österreichischer Sicht
massiv rauszukommen militärisch
Situation um ehrlicherliche Ergebnisse
von der Friedensverhandlungen zu
ermöglichen
die Souveränität der Ukraine zu erhalten
und das was Präsident silenci und das
Volk will nämlich nicht unter Joch zu
werden das muss jetzt zielt werden und
dafür braucht es eine Gegenwehr
Rückeroberung der Krim so weit würde ich
nicht gehen weil das militärisch
schwierig wird dies zu erreichen die
Außenministerin Frau berberbach hat dies
Jahr postuliert ich glaube das war zu
euphorisch und nicht an der Lage
orientiert
im nächsten Jahr werden
Präsidentschaftswahlen laut Fahrplan in
der Ukraine stattfinden halten Sie das
herrning für realistisch in Kriegszeiten
Wahlen abzuhalten das glaube ich schon
man kann das Organisieren wenn sie da
bin ich optimistisch dass das gelingt
in der Demokratie reden wir dann ja auch
darüber das ist eine Abwahl geben könnte
halten Sie das für klug frage ich einmal
für demokratische allemal aber für klug
in Kriegszeiten Machtwechsel
durchzuführen also nach meinem Eindruck
ist es so dass er selenski im Augenblick
sehr populär ist in der Ukraine man
schaut sich hinterher nicht entscheiden
hier am Tisch aber wäre das Wahlen
setzen ja auch voraus dass kennt man ja
mittlerweile auch hier wieder ja das ist
ein Wechsel an der Regierung geben
könnte ist sowas überhaupt möglich ist
das klug weil ich an Großbritannien
während des Zweiten Weltkrieg denke also
denkbar ist das jedenfalls bei
gefechtigten Demokratien in der Ukraine
wenn ich mir die waren so anschaue kann
man schon zweifeln das ist schon richtig
aber das hatten vielleicht noch nicht
mal so sehen was mit dem Krieg zu tun
sondern mit dem politischen Strukturen
in der Ukraine aber das ist ein anderes
Thema ja wird diese Wahl stattfinden im
nächsten Jahr wird es ein Wahlkampf
geben im Krieg ja das ist doch keine
sich natürlich sehr schwer vorstellbar
warten wir ab als wenn Situation das
zulässt wird dieser Wahl stattfinden es
wird aber auch eine Wahl in Russland
geben die russischen
Präsidentschaftswahlen 2024 und einer
Wahl versteht natürlich und ich glaube
da steht das Ergebnis bereits fest ja
und es gibt Wahlen in den USA die darf
man nicht vergessen denn der Schlüssel
für Friedensverhandlungen und überhaupt
rauszukommen liegt ja nicht in Kiew
sondern definitiv in Washington und in
Moskau und es ist ja Wahlkampf Thema in
den USA es wird auch Wahlkampfthema
nicht der Donald Trump hat sich ja weit
aus dem Fenster gelesen und hat gesagt
wenn ich Präsident wäre wäre dieser
Krieg schon längst beendet das heißt es
ist ein Thema und beiden ist auch damit
konfrontiert und er muss das irgendwo
abräumen vorher und das ist meine ganze
Hoffnung also nicht was in Kiel passiert
sondern was in Washington passiert auch
in Peking und das ist nochmal das
Stichwort von ihnen erfahrt dass sie mit
ihnen noch mal kurz aufnehmen möchte wir
sind in diesen Tagen konfrontiert mit
Bildern von ganz oben vom Himmel über
den USA wo plötzlich ein offenbar
chinesischer Spionage
auftauchte und dann nach einigen Tagen
sehen wir den noch mal abgeschossen wird
vom US-Militär es bleiben aber doch
ziemlich viele Fragen nach diesen Bilder
nach diesen knappen Bildern die uns
erreicht haben hier herr Henning wenn
wir hören dass dieser Ballon dann
irgendwann abgeschossen wurde und aber
vorher ja erheblich lange mehrere Tage
offenbar über amerikanisches Gebiet
geflogen ist ist das jetzt ein Zeichen
von Stärke dass man den abschießt oder
ein Zeichen von Schwäche dass der
überhaupt dahin kommen konnte und
solange über Amerika fliegen konnte naja
also der Einsatz von Balance so
Aufklärung hat ja eine lange Tradition
das muss man glaube ich hinzufügen so
ganz neu ist das ja alles nicht was wir
da erleben dass der abgeschlossen wird
um sich mal die Apparate anzuschauen die
da mit dem Ballon zusammen als
Aufklärungsmittel offen und nicht
dienten das kann ich nachvollziehen
müssen oben hätte keine anderen
Möglichkeiten also nicht hinreichend
Techniker aber den so einzufangen ist
wahrscheinlich so ganz einfach erfahrt
wer das möglich gewesen
nein also
gut man es gab diese Fälle schon vorher
es ist nicht der das erste Mal und das
hat man anders gelöst als ich abschießen
das stimmt
aber gleichwohl natürlich man die
chinesische Behauptung das sei so eine
Wetterbeobachtung die halte ich in der
Tat zu sehr mutig dann hätte man ja auch
die andere hätte man ja die Amerikaner
auch vorher unterrichten müssen dass ihr
Hoheit verlässt wird mehrere Tage über
Amerika und fällt offenbar ja nicht auf
erste Mal ich kann Zeichen auch nicht so
ganz einfach die zu detektieren nicht
denn sie können natürlich über
Radarsystem erstmal metalldetektieren
aber das ist ja nun ein sehr kleiner
Teil oder ein sehr schwierig zu
detektieren so stelle ich mir das
jedenfalls vor und hat sogar Montan aber
hat man sie auch entdeckt ja danach
mehrere Tagen dann bleibt aber auch
weiter in die Frage wenn der Befehl vom
US-Präsidenten am Mittwoch gegeben wird
so schnell wie möglich diesen Ballon
darunter zu holen und es passiert am
Samstag was sagt das dann über die
Führung naja also man musste ja den so
abschießen ah das keine Schäden
entstanden am Erdboden und B dass man
natürlich auch die Apparate sagen konnte
und deswegen hat man gewartet bis das
Meer erreicht wurde war eigentlich ein
sehr sinnvolles Vorgehen aus meiner
Sicht das hat man überlegt sie nicken in
der Fahrt bleiben bei Ihnen nicht auch
viele Fragezeichen bei diesen Bildern
bei dieser Geschichte was ging ihnen
durch den Kopf bei mir ging durch den
Kopf das ist natürlich auch eine
politische Message mal abgesehen von der
militärischen Notwendigkeit den vom
Himmel zu holen das ist natürlich auch
ein Zeichen dass man
durchaus Konflikt bereit ist mir Blick
auf China und das zeigt natürlich diese
große Auseinandersetzung der wir auch
sind zwischen USA und Peking die ja den
Makrokosmos beherrscht wir gucken nur
auf die Ukraine wir schauen nur auf
Russland im Prinzip geht um die Frage
abschießt ja es ist eine es hat eine
Signalwirkung ich manchmal kann das auch
anders klären man kann ja auch anrufen
sagen hör mal ja ihr habt euch verflogen
oder wie auch immer recht also man muss
nicht unbedingt abschießen weil ich und
das ist eine das ist schon eine eine
politische Aussage sag ich mal die Frage
ist nur ob wir in Zukunft in einer
multipolarer werdenden Welt wo wir
Nächte wie Indien haben
USA China Japan auch starke Mittelmächte
ob das die richtige Gangart ist in der
Zukunft ja da habe ich eine Frage zu
nachgefragt Herr fat sie sagen jetzt das
war sozusagen eine Machtdemonstration
ein Luftballon abzuschießen mittwochs
kommt der Befehl von Präsidenten
samstags wird er dann auch schon
ausgeführt der als der Ballon endlich
über mehr ist die ganzen Tage aber noch
Informationen gesammelt hat da hat man
den mit dem Kampfjet oben abgeschossen
und das ist jetzt eine
Machtdemonstration also macht vielleicht
zu viel aber politische Signal auf jeden
Fall nicht aber man kann es natürlich
auch anders sehen das hat verdammt lange
gedauert und wie konnte dieser Ballon da
überhaupt reinkommen wir hatten ja mal
den Fall von diesen Piloten der auf dem
Roten Platz gelandet ist da hatte man
sich ja auch viele Fragen gestellt im
Kalten Krieg die kommt der dadurch ne
die Fragen wird man sich auch stellen
müssen so ein bisschen
erinnern uns der ja auch abgeschlossen
worden ist über Russland mit ähnlicher
Mission gehabt
ganz ein bisschen hinter die Kulissen
blicken wie gesagt
verteidigungspolitisch Sprecher wie wird
hier in Deutschland über diesen Fall
gesprochen möglicherweise ist ja davon
auszugehen dass auch bei uns schon
Ballon rüber geflogen ist und wir den
eben nicht bemerkt haben naja machen wir
uns nichts vor es gibt Spionage über
Satelliten aber eben auch über
Luftballons und dieser Ballon war schon
eine Provokation wenn beiden mittwochs
sagt Befehl zum Abschluss und Samstag
kommt dass das sind immer noch drei Tage
wo China erklären können und die
eskalieren können sie haben bewusst
provoziert das ist meine Ansicht und
über Südamerika gibt es auch eine solche
Ballon gehen Sie davon aus dass bei uns
die Dinge auch schon überflogen sind ich
kann das nicht ausschließen zwei Dinge
erstens es gibt auch ein Wettbewerb
zwischen Autokratien und Demokratien und
das müssen wir betrachten bei Putin wie
auch bei Präsident schief und darum
müssen wir auch für Werte für Moral und
für Stärke der Demokratien werden und
zweitens müssen wir uns auch
sicherheitspolitisch darauf einstellen
das heißt die sicherheitsarchitekten auf
Deutschland was machen sie wenn sie
nächste Woche den Ballon hier überweisen
drittens die Windrichtung stimmt auch
nicht das wird die auch noch hin
wir können das kurze lächerlich erzählen
nein nein nein nein nein nein ganz
ernsthaft ganz ernsthaft also die
konnten den Ballon aus China nur
deswegen starten okay Stratosphäre eine
entsprechende Winter okay jetzt nehmen
wir das Ding fliegt über Frankfurt
also wir müssen unsere langfristig auf
solche Eskalation ausrichten können
nicht dass wir sie wollen aber wir
müssen vorbereitet sein ich will damit
sagen auch das russische vorgehen wenn
es jetzt nicht nur militärisches in der
Ukraine ist ein Dauerläufer es ist ein
Wettbewerb und wird von China und
Nordkorea unterstützt und darauf müssen
wir uns Europa einstellen wir müssen
natürlich auch green Deal machen aber
wir müssen viel mehr Sicherheit das ist
die große Frage die ist auch ganz
wichtig wie wir wo wir in dieser Welt
stehen was wir mit den großen Konflikten
machen und der große Konflikt kam ja im
Kleinen in Form dieses Nina 99
Luftballons plötzlich über momentaner
wenn das über Köln über Frankfurt über
Berlin passiert was machen Sie mit dem
Ballon das ist eine ganz praktische
Frage schießen Sie den ab dann muss
entweder Verteidigung oder Kanzler
müssen entscheiden und da sind wir nicht
vorbereitet deswegen fordern wir ja von
der Union zum Beispiel ein Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat in einer solchen Krise
muss man schnell zusammenkommen abwägen
da müssen die Ministerien zusammenstehen
wie würde das das Militär machen müssen
sie erstmal gucken haben sie überhaupt
die Mitte müssen doch erstmal bei uns
fehlen noch die Basics wir haben doch im
Moment eine nicht einsatzbereit
theoretisch klar
aber ich meine Balance sind doch kein
Thema für unsere Sicherheit nicht und
und neue Gremien wie Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat auch nicht wir brauchen
eine erstmal eine einsatzbereit
also jetzt hat und die 100 Milliarden
reichen nicht aus dafür da brauchen ein
bisschen mehr investieren und die
Bundeswehr brauchen mehr Personal sie
muss attraktiver werden sie muss wie
Pistole richtig sagt in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft sind ob mit oder bewerflich
aber da steht sie nicht
sagen
ganz einfach Frage mit oder ohne also
ich glaube schon dass wir darüber
nachdenken müssen die Wehrpflicht wieder
einzuführen wie wollen wir das denn
machen die Landes und bündnisverteilung
wir brauchen noch Manpower die
Bundeswehr mit 180.000 Mann und dem
Material was er da auf dem Hof haben
nicht da vieles nicht einsatzbereit das
reicht doch nicht ne das ist eine Mammut
Aufgabe das kriegen wir auch nicht
nächstes Jahr über nächstes Jahr aber
die Basics fehlen doch wir brauchen ja
auch eine sehr Motivation bei Umfragen
unter 20% der Deutschen sind überhaupt
bereit mit der Waffen Jahren für
Deutschland zu kämpfen bei einer Partei
die vor allen Dingen mit der Kriegs
Rhetorik in Ukraine richtig mal die
Tante unterwegs ist da ist es
wahrscheinlich gar keiner so wenig
Patriotismus
ja ich glaube wir haben ein Problem in
Deutschland mit dem patientismus wir
verstecken ja auch die Bundeswehr im
Grunde war Nationalfeiertagen wie die
Franzosen hier Nationalfeiertag gegeben
und bei uns hat man eher den Eindruck in
der Begriff Veranstaltung
also und das muss man einfach sehen das
gehört mit zum Gesamtbild also ich
glaube schon dass wir uns umstellen
müssen wir brauchen mehr Patriotismus
glaube ich in der Tat wahrscheinlich
Wehrpflicht im klassischen Sinne sehe
ich eigentlich eher als unrealistisch an
aber eine allgemeine Dienstpflicht auch
aus integrationspolitisch Ansicht also
ins Israel zum Beispiel ist natürlich
ganz wichtig für die Integration wir
sind bei der fertig gewesen deswegen am
Ende dieser Sendung noch mal ganz
schnell zu einem Orte zurück sie haben
gedient sie saßen auf dem Leopard sie
sind mittlerweile im Bundestag das heißt
sie sind davon etwas weiter entfernt und
doch wenn wir über diese Themen in
diesen Zeiten reden könnten Sie sich
vorstellen noch einmal dorthin
zurückzukehren können Sie vorstellen
Leopard noch zu fahren
jeder muss das machen was er kann und da
gibt es gut ausgebildete Soldaten und
sie stellen mir die Frage der ich immer
gesagt habe wir brauchen mindestens zwei
Prozent für die Bundeswehr und wir
müssen uns modernisieren und viel
stärker aufstellen und wir haben als CDU
ja auf dem Bundesparteitag beschlossen
eine verpflichtende Gesellschaft ja weil
ich glaube dass das nämlich nur sagen
wir brauchen nicht die Wehrpflicht nach
alte Muster aber wir brauchen dazu
fähige und bereite Bürgerinnen und
Bürger war es aber gerade was erfahrt
ihr auch angesprochen hat dass nur noch
ein winziger Bruchteil der Deutschen
überhaupt bereit wäre das Land das
eigene Land zu verteidigen sie gehören
dazu ich gehöre dazu und dafür müssen
wir auch werden dafür müssen wir
einstehen wir müssen vor allem als
Politik die Mittel zur Verfügung stellen
und da hat mal eben der Einzelplan 14
Absenkung erfahren wird für vier Jahre
eingefroren Herr Pistole ist
aufgefordert das Ding jetzt echt zu
drehen politische Botschaft am Ende
dieser Sendung ich danke herzlich für
die reichlichen Informationen den Streit
hier an diesem Tisch danke an Alexander
danke
ihnen wir sind nächste Woche zurück mit
den richtigen Fragen hier bei uns
[Musik]